want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the 10 principles to win the game of
life
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with principle
number one expect obstacles with tim
grover i think the thing that people
misunderstand about success
is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get that
you know and it's funny
how many people
books have you read or
i won't say promoted but had on your
show and everybody goes
five easy steps ten steps to greatness
yeah no
eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot
count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it and sometimes when you
step on that step you go right into
quicksand but you got to be able to
pull yourself back out of it again so
everybody's looking for these steps and
there are no steps so steps never never
end and you just can't climb steps
sometimes you got to crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom it gets crazy
all right what is that what does that
mean sometimes you're at the top and
then you're at the bottom again well you
may get to the top and you're like i'm
here
and then you look back down and you look
up again you're actually on the first
step
you're on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow it's
literally the beginning
of where you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit it
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like here
look at
i always people that i do the interview
with i always like to use them as an
example because people can relate to
that all right
you've been climbing steps for how long
to get to here
to get
i mean since starting this it's been
over eight years but the journey before
then
it was you know decades to build myself
to prepare myself for this and now i
feel like i'm just getting started right
exactly so you have to do it right
exactly so all the steps that you
climbed just to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps they
don't want to talk about those steps and
how difficult those steps are and how
many steps that you stumbled on and how
many steps you didn't even see and how
many steps that people placed in front
of you and they pulled and they pulled
them all pulled away people that you
were very close to people that you knew
that people that you thought that were
like hey these people actually have my
back except yeah they did have your back
but they were actually pushing you down
the steps
yes
no and
it's funny when you talk about those
things or people talk about them they
seem surprised
but you should know that in that path
all those things are going to be there
they're going to be there principle
number two be a learner with tom bilyeu
you do not need to think that you are
anything special it is absolutely okay
for you to be
hopelessly
average
why
to me the most
powerful thing that you could believe
about yourself is that you're the
average human now why i actually think
it is less powerful for you to think
that you are above average because to
think that you are above average means
you are valuing yourself for being
better than people it's a super
vulnerable position to be in because you
will inevitably meet people who are
better than you and what do you do with
your ego then then it's really crushing
you thought you were the man and now you
encounter somebody that's better than
you they slap you around they out
perform you they dunk on you whatever
and now whoa like you've got to rebuild
and claw your way back
versus
saying the following
the average human is the ultimate
adaptation machine
as a species
humans have chosen
to respond to cultural and environmental
cues so we do not come pre-programmed
like a horse that comes out of the womb
ten minutes later it's ready to rock and
roll it's running around doing all the
things that a horse can do a human on
the other hand has this huge period of
development after birth where we cannot
take care of ourselves we can't walk
can't hold our own head up in our pants
it's crazy
but
what that does is it allows us to drink
in this the environment that we're born
into and adapt
so the average human is the ultimate
adaptation machine therefore being the
average human means you're a learner
that's it you're not exceptional so
you're not putting any of your
psychology your
self-worth your pride into being better
than somebody else
it all comes down to valuing yourself
for being the learner so hey cool you
wasted a bunch of time at school no
reason to hide from that it was a waste
we're not going to repeat the mistake
but we learn so you've got the
self-awareness to see that it was a
mistake now it's just like what do you
want to do what do you want to get great
at because if you apply yourself even if
you're not good yet
you can get good
how do i know that
because you're the average human and the
average human is the ultimate adaptation
machine this is all about disciplined
focused energy
into
acquiring a skill set it's what i call
the only belief that matters when you
believe the time and energy directed at
something through deliberate practice
will actually make you better at that
thing
now all of a sudden it's like i can get
good at anything if i apply myself and
now all of a sudden your behaviors align
with your belief
that's why that belief matters so much
because if you don't think you can get
better at something then why would you
apply any time and energy to it and if
you don't apply time and energy to it
then you really won't get any better
so it becomes this loop of well i
believe i can get better therefore i try
therefore i actually get better
therefore i try harder and you get in
this virtuous cycle
this is hugely important
that is one of those things that will
govern the rest of your life you value
yourself for learning
getting better at something and applying
yourself everything else will take care
of itself because you just keep applying
yourself don't make excuses don't be
asked yourself if you wasted time you
wasted time don't spend your time
beating yourself up over it because we
only do and believe that which moves us
towards our goals principle number three
break your old habits with dr joe
dispenza we have a huge frontal lobe and
it's 40 of our entire brain
and most people
when they have a thought they just think
that that's the truth and i think one of
my greatest
realizations in my own journey was
just because you have a thought doesn't
necessarily mean it's true
so if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts in
one day and we do and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before and you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny your life's not going to change
very much because the same thought leads
to the same choice the same choice leads
to the same behavior the same behavior
creates the same experience and the same
experience produces the same emotion and
so then
the act of becoming conscious of this
process to to begin to become more aware
of how you think how you act and how you
feel it's called metacognition and so
then
why is that important because the more
conscious
you become of those unconscious states
of mind and body
the less likely you're going to go
unconscious during the day and that
thought is not going to slip by your
awareness unchecked
because you're
it means to know thyself and the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you become familiar with the
thoughts the behaviors and the emotions
of the old self you're retiring that old
self as you fire and wire new thoughts
and condition the body into a new
emotional state if you do that enough
times it'll begin to become familiar to
you so
it's so important
uh just like a garden if you're planting
a garden you got to get rid of the weeds
you got to take the plants from the past
year and you got to pull them out the
rocks that sift to the top that are like
our emotional blocks they have to be
removed the soil has to be tenderized
and broken down we have to we have to
make room to plant a new garden so
primarily we learn the most about
ourselves and others when we're
uncomfortable because the moment you
move into that uncomfortable state
normally a program jumps in when that
program jumps in it's because the person
doesn't want to be in the present moment
and engage it consciously
so when you teach people how to do that
with a meditative process
it turns out that when they're in their
life
they're less likely to emotionally react
they're less likely to be so rigid and
believe the thoughts they were thinking
they're more aware of when they go
unconscious back into a habit and that
is what starts the process of change
and so we have to unlearn before we
relearn we have to break the habit of
the old self before we reinvent the new
self we have to prune synaptic
connections and sprout new connections
we have to unfire and unwire and re-fire
and rewire we have to unmemorize
emotions that are stored in the body
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new motion like deprogram and
reprogram that's the act and it's a
two-step process principle number four
set an intention with mel robbins i have
this habit of every single morning i
stand in front of the mirror and i take
a moment and i raise my hand and i give
my reflection a high five and there is
so much science behind this so instead
of seeing yourself
right and have having this moment in the
mirror you know what the average person
does first of all we beat ourselves down
so i would look in the mirror for 40
some years and be like oh my god my
freaking jowls look like saddlebags on a
goddamn horse going in the grand canyon
my eyes have my neck is only striped my
boob one boob's hanging lower than the
other i look like my gray hair like i
start bringing myself down
and when you start going down that road
with your reflection
then your thoughts go to i didn't get to
that email i forgot to text lisa back i
oh my gosh the dog still needs to be
walked i've got nine minutes for my
first zoom you're now
checking out
and that moment in the mirror every
morning
could be a profound moment
where you lift yourself up
and you check back in with your
intention
so the first piece of research and this
is recent from harvard business school
is that a simple moment
in the morning
where you set an intention
about who you're going to be today
impacts productivity
how you show up as a leader
it impacts your confidence it impacts
your mood all day long just that simple
moment of setting an intention so that's
research number one instead of
standing in front of the sink in your
bathroom and criticizing your appearance
or mindlessly going on autopilot check
back in and let's teach you to make it a
habit to lift yourself back up second
piece of research and this comes from a
whole field of study called neurobics
neurobics is like aerobics for your mind
i didn't make this up this is literally
you can speed up the development of new
neural pathways by marrying physical
activity
with a change in thought
and so traditionally i know you've
covered this on your show if you for
example were to brush your teeth i'm a
right-hander if you were to brush it
with your other hand
and think uh a new thought
the fact that your brain is focusing on
brushing with your non-dominant hand
activates more focus on the new thought
it accelerates the learning so you take
neurobics a physical activity with a
different thought and let me let's talk
about a high five for example
what does a high five mean to you
that somebody did something awesome or i
did something awesome correct and if you
think about the times in your life when
you've gotten a high five
it's because somebody's like tom you're
amazing tom
get your attitude out of the can you got
this tom you're going to make this shot
tom we can still win i believe in you
keep going
you have a lifetime positive association
with giving other people high fives
stored right here in your subconscious
mind
when you raise your hand to your own
reflection it is impossible for you to
think god i look fat why am i an [ __ ]
i really screwed up my life you can't do
it because your lifetime association
with this motion is all i believe in you
i got you i see you i celebrate you and
so you in the moment of doing it
override decades of negative self-talk
it's incredible
now have you ever gotten a high five
where somebody misses the hand or it's
sort of like it sucks right
yeah what do you do when that happens i
redo it correct
that's because a high five requires you
to be present and there is an intention
behind it
so you can't raise your hand to your own
reflection without now grounding
yourself in the moment
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there principle number five embrace
falling with simon sinek first of all i
don't like the term failure i like the
term falling i think you need
we we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer right
if you have stage four lung cancer or
stage four liver cancer and you have a
mild melanoma with a 99.999 chance of
you'll be fine
both of those things are called cancer
and the problem is they're not the same
thing and failure's the same is the same
which is failure could be absolutely
catastrophic or it could be a minor
hiccup but the problem is we call it
failure so i think we need to use
different terms right failure i believe
is something we want to avoid but
falling is something that happens
naturally and we want to fall and get
get up more often that's what i think is
fall fall fast and get yourself back up
as opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so i i want to embrace
falling because that's that's taking
risks that's trying you only fall when
you push the boundaries right
but the the the the language matters
because it changes our mindset
especially because it's too broad of
definition for failure
so one of the ways we embrace falling
is by when somebody does fall
we don't say what have you done we go
okay try again as leaders
right
or um how can i help you fix it and
we're just a little more relaxed about
it and and we don't swoop in and do it
for them right
but rather we go
so in other words we're encouraging
risk-taking we're encouraging people to
try recognizing that they won't lose
their jobs
that
that
especially if you're more junior you
really couldn't do anything that brings
down the firm anyway
and we have to give people the
opportunity to fall and let them either
learn to fix their own problems or guide
them so that so that they can every
single one of us has screwed up a
bazillion times and the only reason we
are where we are today is because
somebody said all right all right you're
an idiot but try again you know
like that's where i know who did it for
me peter and tamagio my old boss years
and years and years ago the guy would
never answer any of my questions peter
what should i do what do you think we
should do like
if i knew i wouldn't be asking well what
do you think i think we should do this
then do that the guy never answered a
question and if i screw up he goes woof
what are you gonna do
you know
but i never felt fear that i would get
fired ever
i never felt afraid that my job was on
the line when i screwed up
we have to do that for people principle
number six stand out from the crowd with
tillman fertitta
business is a sport and a
competitiveness just like basketball
football baseball or anything and it's
the competitiveness when i was 21 years
old i won my first cadillac selling
shackly vitamins i told myself i wanted
to own my first jet at 35 and and did
you pull it off 100
100 and then when i was in my 20s you
know i said when that forbes 400 came
out i said i want to be on that list one
day yeah so you got to set yourself
goals and try to set yourself apart and
i talk about that in the book is that
anybody can set themselves apart you can
be the best sound guy you can be the
best cameraman you can do certain things
and study your field and then you get a
break because you were such a good
cameraman or you're the best sound guy
that you got recommended to go on this
set and then this set and then all of a
sudden in hollywood you're known as the
best sound guy yeah you can do things to
separate yourself from everybody else by
just working a little harder i have a i
have a shirt that i wear i put a quote
on it be so good they can't ignore you
100
principle number seven influence with
your work ethic with richard montagnes
my grandfather said something to me that
i i say it's the reason i'm successful
and i love to
tell young people this you know we've
spoken at harvard notre dame some of the
top schools in the country and
i always say this and he asked me what
are you going to do i said uh
i'm the janitor i have to mop the floors
he looked at me and he said when you mop
that floor
you make sure that it shines so when
people see it they know that a mountain
has mocked it
and my dad said listen to your grandpa
you know i actually took that on
and this is what i tell people and you
know maybe some people will get it in
somewhat i said as much as i love the
compensation the promotions frito-lay
hot cheetos pepsi the truth is
it was never about them
it was always about my last name
you know it was always about that you
know and
i'm mopping the best i could and i saw
that i was having an influence
and people say how can you have an
influence when you're just the janitor
and i told people there's no such thing
as just a janitor when you believe in
your heart you're going to be the best
no such thing as a waiter a bus driver
and what was happening was
my job was to clean the bathrooms the
lunchroom and all the uh
managers uh offices before they came in
in the morning
so the workers would go into the
bathroom and the bathroom was spotless
it smelled good and they come out with a
smile like hey
who who cleaned that and then they go
into the lunchroom and it was you know
spotless now you know i wasn't
complaining like throw your own trash i
was just cleaning and smell good
and then in the morning the managers
were
opening up their offices and saying wow
who
my office is spotless who you know who
did this and everybody pointed
to that janitor and said
richard montenez and that's when i
learned that
at a very young age that i had an
influence
i could influence people without saying
one word
by my work ethics i i influenced i put a
smile on their face and never even said
anything and then i realized too you
know some of these quotes quote that
are ancient exactly that they're ancient
somebody said
you get promoted by who you know
i said that's not true you get promoted
by who knows you you can say you know
the ceo or the manager all you want but
they don't and that's what was happening
as a janitor people were knowing who i
was just because of my work ethics i
hadn't even spoken a word yet principle
number eight optimize your environment
with james clear let's say that you
wanted to build a better i'll give you
i'll give you an example breaking a good
hat or building a good habit and
breaking a bad one so one of the laws is
to make it obvious and this largely
comes down to like what we're exposed to
each year each day and minimalism and
simplicity plays a big role in this um
in the book i call it environment design
that's basically the strategy so for a
long time i realized that i brushed my
teeth twice a day but i didn't floss
consistently
and when i looked at that habit one of
the reasons that i wasn't flossing
consistently is because the floss was
hidden in the drawer in the bathroom so
i just wouldn't see it you know like i
wouldn't open up the drawer and remember
so i bought a little bowl and got some
of the pre-made flossers and put them in
the bowl and place it right next to my
toothbrush so now i brush my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all i needed to do
to build the habit of flossing every day
on the other side let's say you know a
lot of people feel like they spend too
much time watching tv or playing video
games or just looking at a screen
but if you walk into pretty much any
living room where do all the couches and
chairs face they all face the television
so it's like what is that room designed
to get you to do it's designed to get
you to watch tv
so there are a variety of uh
levels to this you could for example
take the remote and take it off of the
coffee table and put it inside a drawer
or you could take the television and put
it inside like a wall unit or a cabinet
so you don't see it
you could also increase the friction of
the task so you could like take the
batteries out of the remote
after each use and then you know it's an
extra five or ten seconds put it in
maybe that's just enough time if you
think do i really want to watch
something or am i just doing this
mindlessly
you could
unplug the tv after each individual use
and then only plug it in if you can say
the name of the show you want to watch
so you can't like mindlessly browse on
netflix
and i mean if you really wanted to be
extreme about it you could take the tv
off the wall
put it in the closet and then only take
it out when you really wanted to watch
something but the point here and this is
kind of the the principle of environment
design in general which is
you want to put fewer steps between you
and the good behaviors and more steps
between you and the bad ones and imagine
the cumulative impact of living in
environment that exposes you to the cues
of your positive habits and reduces the
cues of your negative habits it's kind
of like you're just gently being nudged
in the right direction each day and
that's just one of the of the ways that
you can sort of design a system that
leads you into better habits principle
number nine change your language with
marissa peer your mind responds to the
pictures and words the fastest way to
change anything is to change the
pictures and words
and it's such an easy thing to do
i'm terrified i'm elated i'm useless i'm
amazing i have no memory my memory is
compelling i can't speak to people what
i have to say
is easy i find it easy to speak to
anyone
this is the most vexing rule of the mind
for every therapist and coach in the
room it's the one my clients have the
hardest time with
your mind loves what is familiar if your
mind could choose it would stay with
what's familiar and never go to what's
unfamiliar we're in a ward city
and that's interesting because years ago
at night they shut the door and we
stayed in the wall we didn't think do
you know i feel like going for a
midnight stroll i think i wonder i'm a
bit bored of being in this same old same
old i want some variety i think i'll
open the gate wander off and find
another tribe they might have killed you
or eaten you
we learnt familiar made us safe who here
notices with their kids and they
literally want the same cup
the same bowl the same cereal i took my
daughter to finland to see santa claus
she watched a little mermaid in finnish
the whole time and she didn't that was
okay in finnish because she knew she'd
watched it 110 times where i'm like babe
his father christmas is only mummy i
want to watch the little mermaid it's
like well next time we'll just stay home
and watch a movie then she did actually
get into it but it made her feel good
she used to play this game she had so
many barbies and ken would come up in
his car and he was picked the same one
he never picked another one to go to the
ball because they like familiar it makes
them safe you know how many kids yeah
they want the same story every night
but familiar also makes us safe so
here's a rule of the mind and it's a
very important rule to put into practice
my mind likes what is familiar and it
doesn't like what's unfamiliar okay
but i can make anything negative
unfamiliar and anything positive
familiar
let's start with praise it's the most
simple but the most powerful
i meet clients who are never praised i
met one girl whose dad said you're so
rubbish just like your mother
god knows what you've got going if any
man asks you out snap them up because
you are nothing
you're not interesting you're not
attractive when you get pregnant you'll
blow up just like her and be a big fat
mess so if anyone wants to be with you i
can't imagine why take them
and she heard that a lot so she had this
interestingly if i've got nothing to
offer the world and i did a lot of work
with her and she went out she went was
just amazing it was like magic this guy
came up and he asked me out and he was
so nice i mean he actually made another
date and he picked me up in his car and
took me out for dinner told me i was
amazing i'm never seeing him again
i'm not really sure no no he was too
good for me i'm like oh
let's change that wording to his
behavior was so unfamiliar
i don't recognize praise or nicest of
somebody believing i'm worth something
and i want to run back to the familiar
guys i have to beg to take me out or
seeing my friends i pay the bill and
they remind me of my dad and i'm like
well guess what you're not supposed to
have sex with your dad so there's a clue
if someone is like your dad i don't
think you should be getting into bed
with them and i think you need to make
that unfortunate people like it when you
make them laugh so she went right so i
said you need to go out with this guy
and this is what you do you keep saying
i will make this familiar he rings me
when he says he will i make it familiar
he texts me i'll make it familiar i will
make it familiar and she ended up
marrying him she's very happy how weird
the other guy called me and said what
happened to me she went what the guy who
never called me you never called me so i
just let you go
so you have to say let's do it with all
of you how many of you find praise a
little unfamiliar
how many of you find praising yourself
even more unfamiliar okay so if you're
never praised and you're criticized a
lot and christmas is familiar when
someone goes wow i love that teacher i
got it free it's got a hole in it i've
had it eight years i loved your speech
didn't you notice i missed out the best
bit no i thought it was amazing i hear
you're the best salesperson in your team
yeah but not in my county there's
another guy way better than me so if
praise isn't familiar you will reject
praise but
you'll add in what's really a criticism
so the one of the best things you can do
that will change your life
is to make praising yourself familiar
and to make criticism unfamiliar and
principle number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is get out
of your comfort zone with rix and gracie
i was 19 years old the guy was
30 something oh he has 120 fights
and four draws so 120 victories and four
draws you know he was never been
defeated wow
and my father pulled me to ios crazy
about representing and he kind of
received a call from the the manager of
the this other guy
and he set up i said no i'm sorry i
don't have nobody to fight
and then i said dad please pull me in
pull me and pull me and i said i have a
kid here 19 years old
and the manner said no master this guy
is professional he's a very tough guy
and as the guy tried to take my my my
father out of the deal
my father got excited because he felt
like oh i'm gonna have to put this kid
to prove himself but he's good he can
handle so he set up a fight with me
with this guy
his name is zulu
and uh
and i was there to fight the guy
and he have a trademark move which comes
like he starts and then he block himself
together don't get punched get close to
you
put one hand between your legs and lift
you
and throw you back on the floor like
it's like a a move he always does
as he approached that i was quick move
myself back and hit him with my knee
with the best hit i could ever possibly
think
and in my mind
i said
i win the fight for sure was a knockout
and after this he just shook his hand
speed a tooth and
ready to promote i said wow
so that's take me out of my comfortable
zone in terms of
nothing is what i expect right and the
fight goes on for the because it was 10
minutes rounds unlimited number of
rounds so
so when the first round stops
ends i was dead tired
full of his blood
and i was crawling to my my corner and i
said dad
there's no way i cannot go back there
and my dad might even listen to me he
says are you doing great you know he's
worse than you now you're gonna kick his
ass and this and that
said dad i'm serious i'm just dead here
i cannot go and i start to argue with my
dad and and my brother halls throw me a
bucket of ice and and water in my head
and then the the round bang bangs like
bells again and i went to the fight
and like my dad said
i beat the guy in three minutes because
he was already tired i could get a good
position and choke him out
and i noticed my worst enemy at that
point
was my own mind
playing tricks on me
tell me i don't have enough tell me i
was tired tell me i got a loss
so my mind was completely against my
purpose
and i felt like i could not let this
happen ever
so after that fight i make a
a a a statement in my spiritual in my
mind i said i'm not going to quit
anymore i have i prefer to die
then think i have to quit
so since then
i already
creating an element of i'm going with a
hundred percent and if if i fail trying
so be it but there's no quitting there's
no
expectations there's no oh that's got
harder than stuff so based on that
i bring myself mentally to a next level
was a
was an obstacle which to jump that
obstacle
i have to see life different after that
your brain does not want you to hit your
dreams your brain
is designed to keep you small to keep
you safe to keep you protected your
heart wants to create amazing things
your heart has big dreams your heart
sees a beautiful world and says i want
to go make something better and then you
wake up the next day
and your brain takes over and says you
can't do that
that's too risky that's too dangerous
stay small stay safe you didn't go to
school for that and what ends up
happening is this constant back and
forth between your heart and your brain
when you're getting these motivated
moments when you want to do amazing
things and then your brain takes over
again and keeps you small and this is
the path that so many entrepreneurs go
on this roller coaster ride of up and
down and up and down and up and down and
up and down
sound familiar
it's time to get off the roller coaster
and start making progress on your dreams
today's video i'm going to show you how
so
yesterday i got asked on my live stream
evan what's the most important part of
your daily routine
and so many people have so many
different daily routines and it's easy
to do the things like drink a glass of
water in the morning go outside and get
some sunlight and you know all of these
things but the most important thing for
me is actually having my intention for
the day i've actually been experimenting
with writing it out the day before so
this is this is what i wrote last night
of basically my entire schedule
and then more than just what i'm gonna
do more than just what i'm gonna do it's
how i wanna feel what's my intention
going into it so if i look at this i'm
supposed to be recording espresso videos
right now right that was on my list 10
30 am record and espresso videos it's
right there and here get a head start
even though you don't want to
recording videos at the beginning is
always difficult for me there's a couple
reasons why i'm i'm shy i'm introverted
i don't crave the spotlight i don't like
being in front of the camera
i don't i don't i don't do it for ego
purposes
and also i'm afraid i'm afraid
because i want it to be great i want
this video to be the next best video i
don't want to disappoint people my
number one fear is gonna be that i'll
disappoint somebody and so every time
you make something you risk
disappointing somebody where it's easier
just to stay small stay safe don't make
anything today and so it's on my list
the to do right i think a lot of you if
you're watching this video you probably
have a list of to-do's but how many of
you are actually doing the things on
your list of to-do's
the hardest part off is just getting
started
already as i started recording this
video it's a lot easier to keep going
and recording more videos this is the
first one that i'm recording today and
so having that written down
get a head start even though you don't
want to
reminds me of who i want to be
and what i find so valuable about this
is i write this the night before
so the night before you know it's it's
11 o'clock at night i usually sit on the
floor and i review my calendar for the
next day and i write out what i'm going
to be doing and i've added how do i want
to feel what's my reminder to myself
before stepping into that task imagine
you're being your own high performance
coach sitting there telling yourself how
you want to feel remember your intention
before starting that next task
and i knew
okay this is what you always do before
you make a video there's a little bit of
procrastination there's a little bit of
fear there's a little bit of slowness
there's a little bit of
not laziness but there's a little bit of
just apprehension before you get started
why because you don't want to start
because you're afraid because you don't
want to you don't disappoint people so i
write down that message again get a head
start even though you don't want to
because i got a lot of stuff to do today
i got a lot of videos i need to record
today and if it takes me an hour
procrastination before i film that's a
lot of time wasted i could be doing
other things to help grow my business
and push my movement forward so this
this really helps and so when somebody
asks me what's the most important part
of my morning routine it's remembering
the intention how do i want today to go
not just having a list of to do's but
actually writing down how you want to
feel and that message to yourself to
give you the extra push that you need to
move it forward so how do you do it i'm
going to give you three different
suggestions i think will help you
shortcut that talk in your brain and get
you into action mode
the first thing is idea to action so
right away as soon as you get an idea
for something just take action on it we
spend so much time in our heads
overthinking over planning over
analyzing over researching over
preparing and then nothing happens
nothing gets created has that has that
ever happened to you you got this idea
that you think is genius and then you
spend all this time over planning over
preparing overthinking and then you
never actually make anything
and then maybe a year or two goes by you
see someone else get rich off of your
idea
i'm still a recovering perfectionist
myself right i lost a 40 million deal
when i was 20 something
because i was just trying to be too
perfect and so teach yourself to
shortcut the brain out you got an idea
you're going to do something about it if
the intention is positive if the if the
goal is to try to serve and to help
other people
idea action idea action idea action do
it
the second thing is come up with your
intentions
whether you want to do my method and the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
a first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what i used to do before writing it down
i just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because i'd often
forget what am i doing today i don't
know i just woke up i'm tired i look at
my calendar and then with each one i
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it how do i want to show up
for this person if i'm making youtube
videos how do i want to show up
on camera how do i want to show up for
my audience how do i want to show up for
you i would just mentally think about
that as i go through the day and i
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar
that's it and how i want to feel the
intention going through each individual
item on my calendar
what i love about this
is i find that i'm a little more
courageous at night compared to in the
morning i just had a day hopefully it
was a good day hopefully i served i
helped
it's often after i answer some questions
on instagram so i'm in the service heart
and mindset
and i think about how do i want to show
up tomorrow if you find that you have
more energy at night or more clarity or
more boldness at night then then do that
think about how do you want to show up
tomorrow what are your tasks write them
down and with each one just write down
what the intention is how do you want to
show up as a human for each one so not
just a list of to do's but how you want
to feel going into each one
look use even as an example every day at
2 30 i spend time with nina
okay
every day 2 30 take a break from
whatever i'm doing spend time with nina
we usually go outside for the walk with
the dogs uh if it's raining we'll stay
inside and do something together just a
quick break in the middle of the day to
spend time together and that's in my
calendar and on my calendar it says
2 30 half an hour break with nina
but i wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with nina i wrote
down
have fun and make her feel loved
i wrote something else down yesterday
but that's my that's my intention for
today have fun and make her feel loved
so last night i wrote that down i'm
looking at nina she's lying in bed she's
you know about to fall asleep and i want
to think how do i want to show up for
her tomorrow for our break
have fun and make her feel loved
so i look at that again this morning
and i look at it again right now
and then here's what's gonna happen at 2
30.
2 30 i'm going to be done filming my
videos i'm gonna look at my calendar
look at my sheet here let's say 2 30
time with nina have fun make her feel
loved
just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
i'm going to show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something i'm going to
show up slightly different
because i reminded myself that it's not
just
a break
[Music]
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved
and so if you do that for all of the
items on your calendar
for every meeting that you've got for
every quiet time that you got for every
creative moment that you've got how do
you want to show up if you can write it
down i love the night before and then
under each one how do you want to show
up that prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self and then set number three is
have a routine that challenges you to be
a better human this is why i make these
videos honestly this espresso series is
supposed to be a morning series that we
release five days a week to help you
start your day with a shot of espresso
with with some love with some
encouragement with people who are doing
more than you you may never meet me you
may never meet john ashraf you may never
meet bill gates or oprah winfrey or
steve jobs or the people that i profile
on this channel but you can learn you
can learn from them i learn from them i
start my day being around them and the
more that you're around these people who
are living the life that you want that
have the belief systems that you want
you will start to adopt those as your
own as well because the people around
you probably aren't those people
right how many of the people around you
are the people that you look to and say
i want to be like that person that
person's got my life that person has my
ideal values that person is living the
life that i want to live
probably not
right and that's okay you can inspire
them to live a better life through your
actions but you need to get that push
and so the more you can create that
environment around you to help you get
it the greater the chances of you
actually going off and accomplishing it
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know warren buffett's 10
timeless principles for success check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the people you
look up to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life part of life is getting
prepared
so that